da ich für meinen vorletztes Video in
Danzig Polen gelandet bin wollte ich mir
danach noch die 350 km entfernte
Hauptstadt Warschau anschauen nachdem
ich nun schon die erste Klasse
Hochgeschwindigkeitszüge in Deutschland
und Frankreich getestet habe bin ich die
Reise im Express Intercity Premium
angetreten aktuell gibt es 20 PKP
Intercity Züge von der Marke als Storm
in Polen die dort unter dem Namen EEP
ausgeschrieben Express Intercity Premium
verkehren viel Spaß bei diesem zugtest
und damit ein wunderschönen guten Morgen
aus Danzig Polen ja ich bin ja gestern
schon hingeflogen für den Youtube-Video
habe ein bisschen in die Stadt erkundet
und ich muss sagen dann sich auf jeden
Fall super cool falls ihr da was
vorletzte Video glaube ich noch nicht
gesehen habt check das unbedingt ab weil
nur auch deswegen ist jetzt der weitere
Plan ich fahre jetzt noch nach Warschau
und dann geht's für mich von Warschau
zurück nach Deutschland von hier
ungefähr 350 km entfernt und für die
Fahrt nach Warschau nutzen wir heute den
IP den Express Intercity Premium der
schnellste Zug hier in Polen natürlich
habe ich wieder die erste Klasse gebucht
heute gibt's jetzt mal einen spontanen
neuen zugtest und ich habe echt Lust
weil ja Polen Zug fahren ich bin mal
gespannt was ist da auch so für Essen an
Bord gibt und natürlich ob mich die
Fahrt überzeugt so wie vor einiger Zeit
haben wir auch öfter mal zugvideos
gemacht ich würde sagen wir lernen gar
nicht lange ich gehe jetzt noch was
frühstücken dann geht's ab zum Bahnhof
und ab nach Warschau ich habe hier heute
Nacht im Radisson Blu Hotel geschlafen
fünf Sterne ja kann man an dieser Stelle
ja mal sagen und ich habe gerade mal 75
€ bezahlt ihr könnt mir ja mal
kommentieren warum die Hotels in Polen
so günstig sind und jetzt heißt es
Abfahrt hier für euch auch noch mal ein
kleiner Eindruck von Danzig da vorne ist
jetzt schon der Hauptbahnhof und da
hinten ist die Altstadt meine Hotel war
auf jeden Fall da hinten in der Altstadt
eine Sache die man hier sagen muss die
Bahnhöfe heißen alle getanzt also Danzig
und es gibt aber nur ein Hauptbahnhof
der heißt glowy und da muss ich jetzt
hin ich habe übrigens für die erste
Klasse nur 60 € bezahlt und damit ist es
das günstigste first classic Ticket was
wir hier gebucht haben ich habe mich
also in Danzig auf dem Weg gemacht zum
Bahnhof und ich muss sagen der Bahnhof
kurz war gerade so ein bisschen
renoviert und Hauptgebäude war
eigentlich geschlossen aber wenn man
sich das hier mal so anschaut echt ein
sehr imposanter Bahnhof und ja dann bin
ich zum Gleis gesteppt habe auf mein Zug
gewartet und dieser Zug kam auf die
Sekunde genau ich habe es für euch mal
nachgeschaut wir haben aktuell in
Deutschland eine Pünktlichkeit der
Fernverkehrszüge von 65% in Polen liegt
die bei 87,5%, also wesentlich besser
65% ist wirklich so bodenlos ne bevor es
weitergeht würde ich euch allerdings
erstmal den Sponser des heutigen Videos
vorstellen der auf jeden Fall auch bei
längeren Zugreisen helfen kann und zwar
ist das blinkist linkes ist eine App die
ihr euch auf Smartphone ziehen könnt und
damit die Kernaussagen von über 5000
Sachbüchern und Podcast ganz entspannt
zum Lesen und zum Anhören zur Verfügung
gestellt bekommen es gibt mittlerweile
27 Kategorien mit ganz vielfältigen
Themen wir haben Unternehmertum
Gesundheit und Ernährung also da ist
wirklich für jeden was dabei gerade auch
für meine Reisen wenn ich unterwegs bin
kann ich wirklich in geringer Zeit also
zwischendurch mir was neues ziehen was
mich interessiert und das wirklich
ziemlich schnell verstehen wenn er
großer Fußballfan deswegen habe ich
beispielsweise ihr quiet leadership von
Carlo Ancelotti nimm Fußballtrainer
aktuell bei Real Madrid war sehr
interessant gut das ging jetzt 24
Minuten oder auch Geldanlagen für faule
auch super das coole ist wenn ihr euch
einen blinkendes Account zulegt könnt
ihr den erstmal sieben Tage kostenlos
testen dann gibt es ein Abo ihr bekommt
aber trotzdem noch 25% auf dieses Abo
mit meinem Code ist alles in der
Videobeschreibung verlinkt und was jetzt
neues mit blinkes Connect könnt ihr
euren Account sogar noch mit eurem
Partner einen Freund wie auch immer
Scheren das heißt ihr habt zwei Premium
Zugänge und zahlt nur einmal also worauf
wartest du noch Check mein Link aus 25%
Rabatt und denkt dran zwei Premium
Zugänge zum Preis von einem also da
macht man auf jeden Fall nichts falsch
und wir machen jetzt weiter mit dem
Video das ist auf jeden Fall die
kleinste anzeigetafa von einem
Hauptbahnhof die ich je gesehen habe
aber ich weiß dass ich zu Plattform eins
muss
platt
[Musik]
die erste Klasse ist auf jeden Fall ganz
vorne
[Musik]
pünktlich
hat man ja auch nicht alle Tage
[Musik]
irgendwie umgebaut naja tschüss danzig
war auf jeden Fall ganz geil hier also
ist echt eine richtig nice Stadt und
jetzt genieße ich aber meine zwei
Stunden 34 Fahrt hier im EIP Zug und
freue mich auf Warschau übrigens ist das
die Route wir sind denn Danzig gestartet
jetzt über dir Schau und dann geht's
hier runter bis nach Warschau ja mit
Auto wird man übrigens 3 Stunden 33
fahren und ich fahre jetzt 2 Stunden 34
habe mich nicht lumpen lassen für dieses
Video wieder die erste Klasse gebucht
habe ich euch auch schon erzählt habe
knapp 60 € bezahlt also echt nicht viel
Geld für diese Strecke in Deutschland
und Frankreich war das Ticket wesentlich
teurer wir machen natürlich am Ende des
Videos auch wieder eine gesamtbewerbung
wenn ich in Deutschland ICE fahre bin
ich jetzt auch nie so will ich ganz
zufrieden mit dem Internet das
funktioniert halt nicht so
flächendeckend manchmal hast du ein
bisschen WLAN manchmal nicht trotzdem
schneidet da Deutschland besser ab das
WLAN hat auf der gesamten Reise nicht
einmal funktioniert ich habe versucht
mich zu connecten aber ging nicht er
schade aber ja auch mein mobiles Telekom
Netz hat während der Zugreise in Polen
überhaupt nicht funktioniert also ich
hatte vielleicht so 10 15 Prozent der
Strecke Internet sonst nicht aber das
war auch gar nicht so schlimm so konnte
ich mich auf die Fahrt konzentrieren und
den Zug schön für euch testen denn was
wirklich interessant war ich habe
plötzlich so ein Menü zugesteckt
bekommen wo ich mir Sachen aussuchen
konnte ein Heißgetränk ich habe mich für
einen Kaffee entschieden und ein
kalkgetränk Wasser Cola Fanta Sprite was
auch immer ist im Preis mit drin fand
ich sehr nice und man konnte sich aus
diesem essensmenü eine Sache aussuchen
also ich hätte gerne auch mehr getestet
aber das ging irgendwie nicht auch wenn
ich hätte draufzahlen wollen so also das
könntesting and that
cake
thank you ach so okay ich konnte jetzt
auf jeden Fall nur eine Sache Ausführen
von diesen Appetizer aber egal ist
umsonst mit dem Preis drin gut jetzt in
Deutschland nicht
[Musik]
thank you thanks
thank you
so Leute Getränke ist auch mit dabei
besser
zu viel
da wir relativ früh losgefahren sind
habe ich mich dann für ein Stück Kuchen
entschieden die vor mir hatten auch so
ein briosh Bagel oder so der sah echt
lecker aus das Kuchenstück aber auch
super lecker und es war gratis das Board
Bistro für jedermann also auch Leute die
in der zweiten Klasse Reise habe ich mir
auch noch angeschaut das unterscheidet
sich jetzt nicht so wirklich von Bord
Bistros von deutschen Fernverkehrszügen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Toilette ist noch kleiner als im ICE
glaube ich aber
naja
da kommt also die ganze shisha kohle ja
Leute hier im Zug läuft immer so Musik
wie im Restaurant und da hinten sitzt
ein Klavierspieler in der spielt das
alles live
okay das war ein Spaß
so nach vorne kann man auf jeden Fall
schon die Skyline von Warschau sehen
sieht bisschen aus wie Frankfurt
der Zug hat die 340 km auf jeden Fall
souverän und schnell gemeistert und habe
war ich schon in Warschau also es hat
sich echt nicht angefühlt wie
zweieinhalb Stunden ich hatte meinen
Kuchen gegessen sind Kaffee getrunken
bisschen nach draußen geschaut echt geil
also pünktlich losgefahren und sogar ein
bisschen über pünktlich angekommen so
Leute angekommen das war auf jeden Fall
eine super entspannte Fahrt muss ich
sagen sehr schnell vorbei
[Musik]
okay Leute ich habe es geschafft
Warschau
dann würde ich sagen kommen wir zum
Schluss zur Bewertung und wir schauen
mal wie viele von den 25 Sternen in den
fünf Kategorien Komfort Essen Service
naturerlebnisfaktor Preis-Leistung ich
gegeben habe starten wir rein Komfort 4
von 5 Sterne sind zwar bequem ich hatte
genug Platz allerdings 555 mega luxuriös
First Class mäßig aber absolut
akzeptabel kommen wir zum Essen habe ich
vier von fünf Sterne verteilt und zwar
deswegen der Kuchen war eins aber
richtig lecker ich hätte liebend gerne
auch noch die anderen Sachen probiert
das ging halt irgendwie nicht und im
Bord Bistro gab es jetzt auch nichts
mega besonderes deswegen hier leider nur
vier von fünf aber die anderen Sachen
sagen auch echt alle lecker aus und es
war halt umsonst im Preis mit drin ja
Service würde ich auch viel von fünf
Sterne geben weil alles easy wird
entspannt kontrolliert die Dame die mich
bedient hat war super nett und sehr
freundlich hätte vielleicht auch ein
Auge zudrücken kann und mir einfach
diesen drei Hörspiel da liefern können
aber naja Natur Erlebnisfaktor naja gut
würde ich sagen ist jetzt nicht
besonderer als in Deutschland oder
vielleicht auch Frankreich zumindest
wenn man Inland verkehrt drei von fünf
Sterne Preis Leistungsverhältnis
allerdings ganz klar 5 und 5 Sternen ich
habe für die erste Klasse nur 60 €
bezahlt also das ist echt super wenn ich
da zahlt man in Deutschland Frankreich
viel viel mehr und ja 55 wir landen am
Ende bei 20 von 25 Sternen und somit auf
jeden Fall passabel und ich kann jedem
empfehlen wenn ihr in Polen seid Züge
nutzen ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt
ja Leute das war's mit dem Zug Test ich
glaube als nächstes ist dann vermutlich
Spanien dran da habe ich auch schon Bock
drauf und schauen wir mal was da so die
erste Klasse im Training zu bieten hat
abonniert den Kanal für diese Videos
würde ich mich sehr freuen und ja wir
sehen uns haut rein Leute ciao